[Applause]
yeah I won't go anywhere without my team
okay they told me okay first and
foremost thank you for this amazing week
thank you to all my fellow filmmakers
and thank you for your beautiful work
Thank You Shaun and Hector taught the
whole team you are all just amazing it's
a privilege for me to be standing here
and receiving this award but I am aware
I'm not standing here for myself and I'm
aware of it now more than ever I am
standing here we are standing here as a
German Kenyan team for the people who
were part of the to event who stood up
and stand up for each other and who
faced situations like this in various
forms on a daily basis we are sending
here for all the amazing team members in
front of and behind the camera we wanted
to have them here all of them but
despite the fact that they were invited
by the Academy for the right
despite being invited by the Academy and
most of them also because some of them
were Muslims didn't get their visas so
to each and every single crew member of
the Kenyan team where were named Zuri
oco-2 Sawa Asante sana I mean this is a
good sign that people want to hear
stories about kindness and solidarity so
let's please try to keep see and find
and tell more of them because I think
that's how we can change reality okay I
have to talk thank you to the Hamburg
media school family and all our great
teachers professors are writing out
thank you for trusting us Twitter you
first saw it again lettuce an onion
pizza Jota this film is what it is
because of those guys here you had rocks
of beginning and end script writer and
editor always searching for the simple
truth with a big heart for people and
situations to be our schools over there
the producer who never sleeps and who
showed almost superhuman power and
commitment to the project
Felix trigger DP and his attention to
detail this guy his finely tuned eye for
emotional content and his respect for
everything that happens in front of the
camera so I have to talk quicker all the
people from lightbox Africa very
important though a few of them are here
and Bremer I row always for seeing a lot
of challenges and possible solutions
Majid Yaga not here hashtag women in
film production power and said hashtag
odometry and Christine Solana who
managed everything even the toughest
challenges while always reminding common
kind so many more
Llewelyn anthem Lola Milan Mary Suki
Valerie Tony Martin karma everybody you
just got it just where amazing great
cast
Nemo up defies I barked at sodden Naima
Charlie thank you also for an a very
important part of this movie solve the
powerful music by Elizabeth Kaplan a
free and Hirschman and the sublime voice
of um kaya thank you to all our families
and people who supported us in every way
and yeah my personal thanks goes to my
family mama papa Maria gets my six
siblings our Emeka actually would spit
Donna target escaped it's been receive
invites or heaped we've gone mark thank
you not only for the skills that kept me
going
Peter shouts for your elegance and
wisdom and my best friends in the world
in order of appearance
Danny flew in chess and now I also get
to say those famous words for what to go
to all of us thank you to the Academy
Asante sana
[Applause]